Marjorie Taylor green radical republican
congresswoman she spoke at uh one of the
Trump rallies at this point who even
knows which one it is
she is not even pretending anymore she
is fully doing the replacement Theory
thing this is the white replacement
Theory or great replacement Theory take
a listen
aliens are on the verge of replacing you
replacing your jobs and replacing your
kids in school and coming from all over
the world they're also replacing your
culture and that's not great for America
for a long time we knew that these folks
were pushing this idea
but they still had to sort of pretend
not to or they had to couch it in
different language or they had to figure
out a way to make the case that it's not
horribly xenophobic and in many cases
racist they've given up on that and the
idea here there's kind of two layers to
this white replacement Theory great
replacement Theory the idea is the left
Democrats Marxist Communists like fill
in the blanks right whoever whoever it
is that they claim is doing this stuff
the George Soros right fill in the
blanks
they are they are actively trying to
bring people into the United States
including through undocumented
immigration
in order to replace
the current demographic realities of the
United States another way to say it is
the left is deliberately by any possible
means that that they can think of trying
to change the racial and ethnic makeup
of the United States in order to then
what whatever you know win elections
change the culture or whatever that's
the idea of it and it's often kind of
the undertone to a lot of the reporting
on shows like Tucker Carlson and others
about immigration and the debate around
immigration
that's what it is
the there's many issues with it but one
of the issues that exists with that is
that if you start to believe what
Marjorie Taylor green is saying
you start to justify
violence
attacks domestic terrorism whatever
against Americans against the country
against leftists because you believe
that that is what they are doing you
start to believe there's a concerted
effort to root out white people
generally is the way that it goes and
when Marjorie Taylor green says this
stuff it is a form of stochastic
terrorism that could incite or encourage
exactly those types of attacks so this
is extraordinarily dangerous rhetoric
um you know you're never going to charge
her over it as we've talked about before
whether it's Tucker doing it or whoever
not going to charge them for it
certainly not under the current law and
I'm not necessarily even arguing the law
should be changed I mean we have free
speech and there's limits but they're
quite loose okay but we have to
understand this for what it is it is
painting an untrue picture of the goals
of those left-wingers that they talk
about and it's dangerous it's xenophobic
it's racist it's all of these things the
crowd it resonates with the crowd
but they don't even really understand
how they're being manipulated and sort
of directed by it and they're not going
to stop because they're doing really
well pushing exactly this sort of stuff
the David packman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers I've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books I read I
love reading I read all the time but
there's even more books I don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
Blink is connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below